on this episode I bring it to London
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is
Gary B hey everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 193 of
the askgaryvee show
[Applause]
well
[Applause]
we are in London big shout out right
from the gate for IBM hosting us down
here we are we work an amazing company
thrilled to be here we are part of the
we work family at vaynermedia in San
Francisco and on April 1st vaynermedia
is coming to London so excited about
this before we get into the show d-roc
one we should probably brought India
that was a mistake
and two and two we will at some point
have to have some conversations after
we're done with the show with a bunch of
you because I'm very excited now that we
are in London I've decided that it's
time for me to actually cheer for
properly a football team outside of the
New York Jets
so let me London let me give you my
criteria here's my here's my criteria
number one they have not won anything
for 25 years or more number two number
two number two they need to have an
all-time devastating loss that I have to
watch with my own eyes
okay so we'll do that later actually
they'll probably be the question of the
day what football team should I cheer
for all right so I think it's time to
get into the show I'm very excited so I
think we're gonna do it much like we did
should have been a little bit more all
right let's do it
where are we
beautiful anybody see that man right
there do you love it what's your name my
friend how are you
how would I turn podcasting itself into
mainstream culture do that specifically
yeah I mean or do you mean your podcast
podcast yeah I don't think that that's a
very good idea I don't think you go and
make a consumption platform mainstream I
think what you do is you reverse
engineer when things go mainstream and
ride them to me I have no romance of
platform I don't have a romance to
television or radio or mobile devices or
social networks or podcasting or written
form what I have what I have romance for
is your collective attention and then
riding those platforms I mean look I was
excited about podcasting with OTO years
ago what you know and it's been funny to
watch when you know what's interesting
about podcasting is I think it's about
to get even far more mainstream as we
start going into the smart application
of cars and blue 2 than those functions
where people going to be really
consuming these podcasts at scale while
they're traveling and so you know to me
for me the thought of taking a
some should platform mainstream is a way
too big of a deal to actually pull off
be it's pretty historic my man the
written word audio and video are the
platforms where they get delivered
evolve that doesn't satisfy you but he
wanted you leave the like I don't leave
any unsatisfied customers at least when
they're live when you guys are watching
I mean I can't figure it out but while
we're still here go ahead you need more
listeners no [ __ ] you need more
listeners retailers we need more
shoppers painters before people go into
museums that's not for you I wouldn't
this is the point you can't force human
beings to do what you want what you have
to do is respond to what they actually
do got it
I wanted in 2006 10 years ago for more
people to watch YouTube because I had
the only show that was doing anything
but I couldn't force that I want badly
than more than 14% of money to be on
e-commerce in America 20 years after I
launched the e-commerce wine business
but I can't have that
got it so like what you need to do is
realize podcasting enormous and I have a
feeling that you're not podcasts father
I feel like you have podcasts within the
ecosystem of podcasting and you should
recognize there's plenty of attention
for you to be successful so why don't
you win over the people that are
actually there than worrying about
everybody to get on it
[Music]
you gotta better let's move
who's got a question what do you think
do you rock that's good I thought I was
stronger how are you good to see you
thanks for coming let's say who made it
out last night from meetup much love
thank you thank you yes well I mean a
lot you know I think the number one
piece of advice I have for a 19 year old
is always patience I think for a lot of
us here most of us not everybody there's
some youngsters in the crowd but we've
all been there and I think the
impatience so many of us have at 19
tends to be the detrimental aspect of
our personality I think there's way too
much wanting it now now now which then
leads to very short-term behavior and I
always say to a lot of my friends I'd
like look there's a very big difference
between being rich and being wealthy if
we're talking about money within the
context of the business and really
normally it's predicated on people that
are thinking in a 20 or 30 year window
versus people that are thinking in a 20
or 30 minute window and so I've been
very concerned and a lot of you have
seen this for me because you're not here
if you don't have know some of my feel
I've been pushing very hard against
these 22 and 23 year old business and
life coaches who are on Instagram
selling a [ __ ] lifestyle and try to
get people into their mastermind and
$800 ebooks and and the reason so many
of you 19 year olds the market are
falling for it is cuz you want it now
you know I can only speak from the
advice I can only give advice that I
took myself I built a business from 3 to
60 million dollars and more specifically
from 3 to 25 million dollars in a three
year window as a kid and building a
business from 3 to 25 and it's yours too
then also pay myself at that time still
$40,000 a year is me eating my own dog
food I was patient
I was putting every one of those dollars
back into the business because I knew
that it wasn't over at 26 or 28 or 32 so
many of you as you build something or
extracting dollars out so you can buy
things like Duncan watches and and like
a car and just dumb [ __ ] instead of
putting that money back into the
business because you're building
something long-term so my number one
piece of advice of nineteen is one
patience it is I'm still patient and I'm
old I'm 40 and I'm old maybe not to some
of you but I'm done I mean do you
remember when you were 19 I thought
people died at 40 so so so so I think
that I think patients I think you need
to understand that you're not entitled
to [ __ ] you know I think a lot of people
at a younger age have this fascination
and that Millennials when us 40 year
olds were 19 when us 60 year olds were
19 there's an entitlement early on cuz
the market hasn't punched you in the
mouth yet right and so people think that
just mean this and especially right now
just because you start a business
doesn't mean you're entitled to winning
right it's insanity everybody thinks you
just get to say you're an entrepreneur
and then good [ __ ] happens
I mean the data is against you 98% of
you were gonna fail hard and go work for
the man that's right the market says you
98 out of hundred times so why do all of
a sudden because there was a social
network the movie and because the shark
tank and lions then and all this [ __ ]
everybody thinks anybody can do it so
patience betting on your strengths
figure out who the you are right listen
learn and don't let me promise you two
things
there's no 9 week process to make money
right there's no 7 figure expert that's
going to show you the way it's hard work
let's move it I like it I like how
you're running around there we're in the
back yeah and then we'll get to the
front back left hands anybody got some
back left hands there's some I mean if
you call that running you're super out
of shape that seems like a super slow
skip hello darling I know who you are
all the time good to see you okay okay
[Music]
yes nobody
I love it let's climb it up for the
banana nobody be Rocky
yes this by the way for a lot of you
that only watched the askgaryvee show
this comes from what I'm putting out on
snapchat so if you're not following
follow you're welcome nope
[Music]
[Applause]
guys this isn't the [ __ ] biz dev with
each other shop Instagram number one
because it's soft porn and I need that
we're gonna keep it real right come on I
didn't really hear it desert island yeah
yeah
Instagram soft porn one apps
I mean Safari so I'd have the entire
internet set I mean I didn't need
anything after that and probably I'm
probably
I mean if there was only one other dude
on the island Grindr would be right and
and I would say and probably messenger
right like the default messenger thing
just communication tools cool thank you
let's do it it's got a question
Grindr that was really well done how are
you good stand up brother what's your
name good you are you I am yes I'm not
into it now it is a massively proven
successful way to go about doing
business I wish my homie Jason freed the
founder of 37signals was sitting here he
punched me directly in the mouth and he
would be right because for Jason freed
and DHH the way they built our company
or Matt Mullenweg
who's built a billion-dollar company
automatic WordPress they have built it
on absolute only remote operators and
employees I for me self-awareness Gary
Vaynerchuk don't like it I don't even
like having satellite offices right like
I don't like it I want to I want to be
very hands-on
I'm very touchy-feely I scale and build
my business by walking by people's desks
and can feel that I literally sometimes
go to the bathroom to take a piss right
walk walk by somebody don't like the way
it felt and as I'm going to take a piss
text my HR company I'm like I need to
see Rick for five minutes
and so literally how I built my company
that's how I feel my companies I'm built
on EQ it's funny when everybody says
social media was like not human and it's
bad the reason I know the reason so
optimistic about social media or
technology is technology's a gateway
drug to human connection I know it
because I only live on human connection
I just used that stuff to scale without
social media and technology there
wouldn't have been one person on the
corner of that street last night let
alone 300 I used it to have the three
and a half hours I had with all of you
by one by one by one because of it was
the enabler
now remote workers could do that but for
me to be successful I really like the
idea of having it together Team Dynamics
I'm a guy that loves sports clearly I
like team dynamics it's not for me I
don't like when people work from we had
to force people from to work from home
for a year because we were growing so
fast and we ran out of space and fire
codes and everything and it was the
worst year I hated it you know I don't
feel that people are as productive I
don't give a [ __ ] what you say I don't
believe you right you know and so like I
don't like it like and so it's not for
me as an operator to run a company for
me but for a lot of people it could be
great
I will never build a company that has
remote employees at scale ever it will
never happen
oh cool you got it let's get up here
let's get some peeps up here sorry great
running bro going to race for the food
planning stuff that were interested in
responding to that yes you now both to
askgaryvee yes and very much your show
is now
not true all out it's all listening [ __ ]
nothing should film think about what you
just said let's break it down askgaryvee
is completely predicated on me listening
to you first
yes yes yep yep yes yeah well then I'm
doing a poor job like you no I
understand
because how could I argue that if that's
what you feel so so maybe my bad job was
the you know like the tactic of it being
askgaryvee instead of asked everybody
right maybe it's something like that I
don't know man like I've never felt like
I've been able to provide more value
than I'm doing right now maybe the
positioning maybe just what's going on
with the positioning is throwing it off
but I've never been at the scale of
engagement so thank you economy it you
know I really feel like this is an
absolute evolution of it because instead
of me putting out content that I want to
put out it's completely predicated on
everybody else right I'm answering and
engaging more than I ever have
I'm producing more about myself than
ever maybe that's the shift right never
had d-roc following me around so I have
empathy for where you're going with it
yeah yes and I've been asked that same
question yes and so you're worried that
I'm going in the wrong direction
I'm asked by the way I'm a big boy like
I'm I respect
yeah being I was wondering whether my
popular through some of the biggest
speakers in the world okay well why is
it [ __ ] okay when they basically go from
being completely humble about yeah
everyone try not to yeah a little bit in
the InDesign in that in the tornado dude
yeah no listen I think it's a great
question I think it's a very fair
question keep the mic cuz we're still
jamming I think that um I think that
number one I've always been egotistical
and and and humble at the same time like
I'd built a 65 million dollar business
as a kid before I came out and did
anything I had plenty of ego before I
even did that right I think that you
know to me I think that um I never worry
about this and I'll explain why I always
know what my intent is I only think the
giving has exploded more of the
attention because I'm doing it even
better like I think the reason there's
more of this going on is because I've
done it better with askgaryvee because
I've given more than I used to believe
it or not because I created structure
around the giving you know I I so much
have empathy for where you're going I'm
not too worried about it because all
those people that you're talking about I
don't think they go and spend three and
a half hours in the corner you know yes
I feel centered man I you know I you
know I think look I think it depends
what one cares about right so for
example I wish we really deeply knew
each other because if you can't if you
lived in my brain you would be
flabbergasted by how much money I leave
on the table if my CFO was sitting here
he would hit you know the club you know
it's so insane how people that are
closer to me who actually have access
like Wendy Rock was a fan and wanted to
make a video versus do you rock today
who has access right d-roc likes me so
much more because he knows the truths
behind your question right I can't worry
about it because I know it ABS and flows
right like
there was a you know an early time in
web 2.0 where I really had it at South
by it was I was one of two or three
people then I decided I needed to build
another business to have the audacity to
talk to people about business so I got
quiet if you think about it for me
between eleven to fourteen right then I
was like wait a minute
like I think I'm like I really learned a
lot let me go into a Q&A show because
when I was doing keynotes my Q&A part
was where people really liked it and
instead of me saying that I want to talk
about social networks or this stuff
let's see what they want right so you
know like listen I know the biggest
speaker and personal brands - I have not
made my money in that environment I you
know when you go list everybody you're
about to list I've made way more of my
money building actual businesses I mean
if my CFO or my accountant were here
they'd hate that I do this they're like
you build businesses they know who's
come from four to a hundred million in
revenue you don't make more money in a
month if you if you don't stop speaking
stop writing books stop doing this I
don't want to I like this I I do this
more out of the vanity of I like the
interaction and I like the feeling it
feels to be loved like this because my
mom loved me so much
I'm not I'm again it's very important to
me the other big speakers don't have
businesses that are built to make money
not off that audience I don't want
anything from you
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone else you're about to meet they
want his money
I don't every three years I say can you
buy something for 18 bucks right and
even then if he doesn't give up what it
feels like to answer emails at 3:00 in
the morning all day engage put out the
content I know you do and then when you
start promoting four five or six weeks
an $18 book not a $25,000 a year
mastermind not an $800 ebook but an $18
book and then somebody comments like
Gary Vee you're a little much on
promotion I'm like really like like and
then and then I get crazy because I'm
crazy and I'll click that person and
I'll go look and this there's paying
some guy ten thousand dollars to be his
coach
who's a loser
and I appreciate you and the reason I
wanted to jam was in dialogue when we
get to that punchline it becomes
important and I appreciate you giving
kind of that feedback of I I don't for
me to be all about me for them the right
move is then to take money from them
that's the move that you're referring to
and now like speaker world that's what
they try to do they try to monetize
their audience I'm not right I'm looking
for legacy I'm looking for legacy I want
their emails in nine years that's what
gets me off I've made a lot of money you
know I need a lot of money already like
money is not driving me I'm gonna get
that I did that before I came onto the
scene I'll get that one I'm quiet right
like I like the interaction
I like the legacy I like the feeling I
like people liking me I got that vanity
for sure but don't let that vanity
confuse that I'm trying to do something
wrong and take the dollars and that's a
different thing and so the reason I
never worry about well it's all about of
course it's all about me and it's
equally all about you and I think that
the way people consume me is a
reflection of where they're at with
themselves and that's how I use it to
navigate you know
that's it can I get one more give me one
more rod we can do one more
thank you much alright one more this
beautiful lady right here there we go
right there
well you don't call her a woman what are
you what do you want real quick this
women [ __ ] did you see that woman
that's a woman she is here don't come
with that [ __ ] well what do you want
me to force people to walk in here
listen let's let's go on the street
problem but listen I wish this whole
room women and you know what the total
price of that was zero dollars some
ideas to drive it forward how do we do
it yeah we're great in the UK we're
doing wonderful work okay we're at the
top of the field right
yeah the US yes and no no I love it I
love it I like I'm using bloody this
week to I'm like holy [ __ ] I love I love
it tell me tell me tell me what the
business is okay
and so what does that mean
it works it's a diet Club it's the kind
of weight which is okay so with an
exercise element as well okay got it
and so you're looking for people to buy
into your franchise and sell and so what
did you do in the UK okay so what's the
difference between the US what let's
talk about it this is no we're here for
a reason yeah I mean look I think I
think listen we're I'm spending all my
time trying to figure out how I'm gonna
come to the bloody UK right like like so
I'm with you they're all different and
there's context I respect that
here's my question my question is have
you tried yet to recruit for US
consumers
okay that's fun we comes in with that
but with Facebook marketing social media
marketing do we need to be targeting
different people different element have
you done it no well that's the first
problem the first and this is where I'm
going down this path you're doing you're
doing classic non-us business coming to
the US mentality that's where I'm going
let me explain there is an inferiority
complex to businesses that are based
outside of the US when they come to the
US because people know the u.s. is a
very big market it's a very competitive
market and I always tell my entrepreneur
friends of all shapes and sizes that
when you come to the US if you're good
enough you're gonna win right I think
what the reason I was going down the
path of my questions is you've already
made assumptions without actually doing
it you have you me no I do not
here's some good news I have no [ __ ]
idea but first you gotta try to figure
out if you have to do that like like
like that's what I was able to sense
like you can go first
execute your model before psyching
yourself out that your model won't work
there cuz it's different yeah that's
what you've done did to get here here
well then you don't know you need to run
that blueprint everybody's tell me like
Gary you got to run a different you
blueprint in the UK I'm like you I'm
gonna run I'm gonna I'm gonna write I'm
gonna run my blueprint now if the market
says cue back then I'll adjust well they
say that in UK you know there's you know
American business is coming they're a
little too American and you got to make
sure you have your humility and I'm like
that's a problem because I'm too
American for Americans you know and just
classic stuff like that it's different
this is what everybody does everybody
does it because it comes from a sense of
pride Americans are gonna tell you it's
different
because they're prideful that America is
so competitive it's not different you
just have to be good bloody brave you
know what's funny well forget about that
first you have to just do it you can do
it you don't even have to be brave you
just have to do it so you can taste it
to see what and how you
to adjust I think so thank you alright
that's it for this part London thank you
so much let's clap it up for each other
and it says question question of the day
what English Premier League team should
I support you keep asking questions I'll
keep answering them
[Applause]
[Music]